NoNotre panel ce soir avec
StStéphanie Grammond, Castonguay
etet Stéphanie Chouinard, bonso.
P Personne va se réjouit
cocomprendre COVID encore une
fofois, mais on n'a pas d'autant
plplus qu'il y SEPQ a confirmé
ququ'on était aujourd'hui bel et
bibien plongé dans la sixième
vavague ça se voit depuis une
sesemaine que les chiffres ont
dédémontrée, hausse des cas, des
hohospitalisations, même si les
cacas sont sous représentés, on
vovoit une tendance. Ce qui est
ététonnant, c'était pas plus tad
quque dimanche que le directeure
lala santé publique par intérime
vovoulait pas confirmer qu'on
ététait dans une sixième vague,
dodont quelques jours plus tard,
onon le confirme que les ça vous
ététonne?
- - +-, Souvenez-vous de Horacio
ArArruda, qui après la première
vavague avait pris beaucoup de
tetemps à confirmer la deuxième
totoujours très prudente ou de a
sasanté publique, on se demandei
c'c'est un soubresaut, ça prend
totoujours quelques jours avant
quque l'évidence impose et
coconfirme qu'il y a bel et bien
unune sixième vague, c'est INSP,
dodonc pas du côté de, mais on a
coconfirmé ce montant sont tousn
réréalité, il y a l'échec de cex
ququi ont un test PCR, 10 % de a
popopulation en accès, mais je e
sasais pas si vous avez au don
d'd'amis et de collègues qui sot
totouchés depuis maintenant une
sesemaine ou 10 jours, mais
c'c'était assez clair qu'on état
dadans ce début de sixième.
- - Les gens régiront
paparticulièrement parlent
bebeaucoup, on se très fort dans
lele Bas-Saint-Laurent, entre
auautres en Gaspésie, sur la côe
NoNord aussi, à tel point que ls
sasanté publique locales
rarappellent les mesures et dist
dede rester prudent, ce n'est ps
teterminé, au contraire. Mais ça
sese fait sentir jusqu'à
l'l'Assemblée nationale, vous
l'l'avez aujourd'hui, on est reu
àà au-delà de sept élus de la
CACAQ, une dizaine des élus de
l'l'opposition qui sont absents
paparce que dans la COVID. M.
LeLegault, ça va s'étirer un pe,
onon le reverra probabablement s
avavant la semaine prochaine, ia
anannulé encore des activités
cecette semaine. Stéphanie, on
vovoit même la chaîne de
cocommandement, quand vous aveze
prpremier ministre qui est abset
paparce que la la COVID, on
apapprend que la vice-première
miministre aussi est absent pare
quque la la COVID, ça fragilise
ququand même un peu la chaîne de
cocommandement.
- -  Oui, c'est sûr, mais ces gs
nene sont... pas, vivent de la
mmême société que tu mens, alors
mamalheureusement, ils ont beau
fafaire attention, je présumee
ququ'ils ne sont pas immunisés
mmême s'ils ont eu le vaccin et
ququ'ils ont suivi les règles
sasanitaires, j'ose le croire, n
lele voit partout, dans les
ununiversités, dans les écoles,
dadans les milieux de travail,
bebeaucoup de gens sont absents,
bebeaucoup de gens ont la COVID,
ououi, on s'en doutait bien, on
avavait une on avait une sixième
vavague, le Dr Luc Boileau avait
paparlé pour ce qu'on était en
roroute le week-end dernier, là,
onon est vraiment bien embarqué
dadans l'autobus, la cinquième
vavague a été tellement difficie
susur le moral, on espérait quea
prprendra un peu plus de temps
avavant que la prochaine vague
vivienne, mais non,
mamalheureusement, donc il va
fafalloir y faire face, n'a pase
chchoix. Et puis peut-être que
mamalheureusement, il y a
cecertaines mesures qu'on a laié
totomber ou qu'on avait laissé
esespérer que ça disparaîtrait,
cocomme le port du masque à la -
avavril, j'ai bien peur qu'on
dodoive garder ça plus longtemps
sisi les choses persistent.
- - Et sur les impressions
l'l'Assemblée nationale, sur le
bobon fonctionnement des travau,
vovoici là-dessus Simon Jolin-
BaBarrette.
SISIMON JOLIN-BARRETTE,
leleader parlementaire de la CAQ
- - On suit les recommandations
dede la santé publique, mais por
leles travaux parlementaires,
onon se réajuste en fonction
dede la réalité. Les deux côtése
lala Chambre, comme l'ensemble e
lala population, il y a des gens
ququi... attrapent la COVID
etet donc s'isolent pour
lala période qui est requise.
- - La société civile, les élus
quque c'est le même monde
fifinalement, alors ils ne sont
papas immunisés contre la COVID.
ReReste que quand même, on a du
rereporter un peu plus tard une
cocommission parlementaire cette
sesemaine, qui était rendu sur e
phphase de détail d'un projet de
loloi sur la loi de l'assurance
auautomobile. Ce que ça a quand
mmême des impacts, l'INESSS
l'l'organisme qui produit des
apappréciations de ce qui s'en
vivient dans le futur, commence
auaussi à sonner la noce SANN
alalamans disant : attention, on
prprévoit des hausses
d'd'hospitalisation, ça pourrait
s's'accélérer. Il n'y a pas une
memesure qui ont été annoncée, n
n'n'a rien resserré pour
l'l'instant. Est-ce qu'on répète
les mêmes erreurs qu'avec les
auautres, c'est-à-dire qu'on
réréagit trop tard?
- - On réagit peut-être autant,
mamais aussi, on a des déconfiné
TéTétraultville, on est
acactuellement danans une situan
onon a un début de qui ressemble
énénormément à la cinquième vag,
mamais on n'est pas du tout làùu
onon était au début de la
cicinquième vague. On a des liex
pupublics où il y a presque plus
dede distanciation sociale, on t
dede retour à 100 % dans les
cocommerces, en Ontario, les
mamasques ne sont pas obligatois
dadans les lieux publics non pl,
onon parle dans les institution,
nonotamment postsecondaires et
hhôpitaux, de faire tomber le
mamandat vaccinal à partir du 1r
mamai. Donc on n'a pas les
coconditions gagnantes pour
s's'assurer que cette nouvelle
vavague ne prenne pas des
prproportions qui sont les pires
paparmi les différents scénarios
ququi nous sont présentés.
- - Lors de la cinquième vague,n
sese rappelle, le gouvernement
avavait réagi assez durement
MiMiradoli dans un grand
coconfinement, mais peut-être ac
unun certain délai, c'est ce que
dedes observateurs haver reproc.
SiSituation se retrouve
acactuellement le gouvernement
apaprès toutes ces manifestatios
dede camionneurs, des gens qui
dédénonçaient qui ne pouvaient
plplus des mesures sanitaires,
l le parti conservateur du Quéc
esest en hausse dans les sondag,
mimise sur ce mécontentement, sl
dodoit prendre de nouvelles
memesures réussissent à
s's'accélérer l'empire, la
sisituation, ça va mettre la das
unune situation difficile.
- - Oui, absolument, mais il
fafaudrait que ça sentait vraimt
bebeaucoup pour qu'on revienne à
soson haver connu. D'abord parce
ququ'on est pas au  Même.
t troisièmes doses sont beaucop
plplus avancées qu'elle ne
l'l'était, en décembre, on avait
papas de troisièmes doses. On a
ququand même la moitié des
QuQuébécois, surtout ceux qui st
leles plus à risque, et plus de0
anans, on est vacciné à plus de5
%.%. Il y a quand même des
didifférences épidémiologiques
asassez importantes, on n'aura s
bebesoin d'annuler le couvre-fe,
leles restrictions dans les
cocommerces que l'on devrait avr
unune rédaction immunitaire
susuffisante pour traverser. Çae
vava pas dire qu'il n'y aura pas
dede hausse d'hospitalisation, l
y y a des gens est vacciné, des
gegens vulnérables et les gens i
vovont avoir besoin. Est-ce quee
réréseau est capable de le
susupporter? Christian Dubé dist
cecette semaine qu'on est capab,
onon a une marge de manoeuvre en
plplusieurs semaines. Capable de
susupporter cette hausse, donc e
pepense que c'est très prémature
dede dire si on est obligé de
rerevenir, il y a une évolution
dadans l'épidémie, dans le virus
dadans la manière dont se
trtransmet, politiquement, on et
enen année aussi plus compliqué,
dodonc le gouvernement va vraimt
prprendre son temps avant de vor
sisi on a besoin de quelque choe
dede plus. Le port du masque à a
mimi-avril, ça me paraît un peu
prprécipité. Est-ce que le masqe
vava revenir dans les écoles,
pepeut-être, gens de maison très
sisimple à mettre en place et qi
fofont une grosse différence. Ms
fefermer les restaurants, les
cocommerces, honnêtement, je ne
vovois pas cela, même à moyen
teterme, je ne pense pas qu'on
enenvisage ça.
- -  M. Dubé pense qu'il y a dea
mamarge de manoeuvre dans les
hhôpitaux, même si l'INESSS
momontre qu'il va y avoir une
hahausse des hospitalisations. .
DuDubé à renouveler les primes,t
leles extensions de finalement,
popour que ça fonctionne dans ls
hhôpitaux, ça prend du personon.
- - Oui, puis on voit que les
ababsences sont en forte hausse
dedepuis quelques jours, une
sesemaine, donc les effectifs ne
sosont pas là, on a besoin de
momonde, alors les primes, c'est
dede retour, tant mieux, et puis
ilil faudra faire ce qu'il y a
popour traiter les gens parce qe
cece sont les plus vulnérables,
leles personnes âgées qui vont
évévidemment écoper. On le sait,
c'c'est vraiment exponentiel, ls
ririsques de hospitalisation por
leles plus jeunes sont quand mêe
rerelativement faibles, mais pls
onon augmente son âge, sa double
prpratiquement à chaque strate e
cicinq ans, donc les gens qui it
àà risque, ce sont des gens, il
fafaut faire attention et je pee
quque c'est la responsabilité de
chchacun dans la société d'être
prprudent et de garder le maximm
dede mesures sanitaires pour que
ceces gens ne soient pas les
grgrands perdants.
- - Pour la clientèle la plus
ââgée, la quatrième d'ores et
dédéjà commencés cette semaine.
PaParlons d'un autre sujet qui
fafait énormément réagir, c'este
cocontroverse dans lequel nage
l'l'université Laval parce qu'ia
lalancé un appel d'candidature
popour une chaire de recherche a
afaffirmé qu'on ne retient que
ceceux qui font parti d'un quate
grgroupes de minorités qui
s's'détail, voici un tableau,
fefemme, membres des minorités
vivisibles et ethniques, aux
pepersonnes handicapées,
A À condition d'avoir les
cocompétences requises, c'est
lalargement dénoncé par la clase
popolitique.
JEJEAN-FRANÇOIS ROBERGE,
miministre de l'Éducation, Québc
- - On veut avoir plus de
didiversité, on veut plus de
fefemmes, on veut plus de membrs
dedes minorités visibles, mais
dede discriminer pour combattre
lala discrimination, je pense qe
c'c'est une fausse bonne idée.
DODOMINIQUE ANGLADE,
chcheffe, Parti libéral du Québc
- - Je suis en faveur du fait
ququ'on doit avoir une meilleure
rereprésentativité, il n'y a aun
dodoute dans ma tête, aucun dou.
MaMais de là à aller exclure
dudu monde sur cette base-là,
jeje pense pas qu'on va dans
lala bonne direction. Je pense
ququ'on va trop loin.
PAPAUL ST-PIERRE PLAMONDON,
chchef, Parti québécois
- - C'est complètement
ininacceptable. Au lieu
d'd'avoir un système juste
babasé sur le mérite de chacun,
pepeu importe nos différences,
onon se retrouve dans un système
ouoù on empêche certains candids
avavec un certain profil
dede pouvoir être évalué
auau milieu de leurs compétences
etet de leurs idées.
- - Alors, finalement, ce qui ne
pepeut pas postuler de façon
gégénérale, pas très rapide, c't
papas mal un homme blanc. Est-ce
quque c'est de la discriminatio?
- - Le gouvernement fédéral
fofonctionne de cette façon avec
totoutes les chaires de recherce
dudu Canada et la façon dont ça
fofonctionne je pense que c'est
imimportant de l'expliquer, c'et
quque lorsqu'il y a l'octroi d'e
chcharte de recherche à une
ininstitution en particulier, le
gogouvernement fédéral va regarr
ququi d'autre à l'intérieur de
l'l'institution a déjà des chais
dede recherche du Canada et s'iy
a a une surreprésentation de
cecertains groupes. Ce qu'on
coconstate ici, à l'université
LaLaval, il y a une
susurreprésentation de l'homme
blblanc, donc on demande à versr
dede tenter de trouver un
éqéquilibre, c'est très connu ds
lele milieu universitaire que ls
fefemmes et les personnes sera
fifinalisé et avec handicap sont
sosous promus dans le milieu
ununiversitaire, pour la
tititularisation aussi. Donc, il
fafaut comprendre que cette
dédécision vient dans un contexe
ququi est beaucoup plus large.
ApAprès, on peut parler de ce qe
c'c'est la discrimination
popositive, évidemment, il y a s
cocontre arguments qui viennent
avavec ce type de décision, mais
cece n'est pas une décision prie
enen vase clos et pas non plus e
dédécision prise seulement par e
dédépartement ni par l'universié
LaLaval.
- - intéressant de voir un peu
plplus largement, mais je vais
cocompléter mon tour de table.
QuQu'est-ce que vous en pensez
ququoi?
- - C'est-à-dire que... en tant
quque homme blanc, je me sens...
papas pu postulait, je pense que
lele fait de baser uniquement sr
lele mérite comme le dit M.
PlPlamondon, historiquement à
avavantager l'homme blanc
ququestion, donc ce système, pae
ququ'on a des biens inconscient,
dedes préjugés non infirmiers,
cecela a favorisé une certaine
rereprésentation de l'homme blac
auautant dans les chaires de
rerecherche que dans les postese
prprofesseurs et donc combattre
celala que c'est une bonne chos,
ilil faut le faire. Université
LaLaval a une politique à
cocompétence égale, si quelqu'un
poposte sur un champ de recherce
quque l'on va choisir la persone
rereprésentant la minorité, dodà
cocompétence égale, on favorise
dédéjà les minorités pour être
cacapable d'avoir une meilleure
rereprésentativité.
- -  Mais c'est pas comme ça que
l'l'appel de candidatures a été
lilibellé.
- - Il y a un groupe qui ne peut
papas du tout postuler, on ne st
mmême pas si dans les autres
grgroupes quelque chose
d'd'intéressant va être année sr
lala table, va y avoir des
cacandidatures intéressants, on
didit d'emblée qu'on ne veut pas
grgroupe de recherches, ça
m'm'apparaît aller assez loin
ququand même dans la
didiscrimination positive que je
cocomprends qu'il y a des
réréticences en disant : est-ce
ququ'on est rendu là, on ne peut
mmême pas trier parmi tout ce
ququ'on a, faut qu'on décide que
cecertaines personnes ne peuvent
mmême pas faire valoir leurs
cocompétences. Ces un peu les
gegens. On pourrait au moins
papasser une vraie amitié et
enensuite choisir si effectivemt
onon peut être plus
rereprésentative. Mais de la
babarrer complètement de la
sosociété, je peux comprendre qe
çaça gigote bien des gens.
- - Est-ce qu'il me restait
vrvraiment 30 secondes? Trois
miminutes et 30 secondes j'ai eu
pepeur. Je vous laisse entendre
StStéphanie Grammond. C'est un
susujet qui est délicat, pour
prprendre le temps d'en parler.
- - Un sujet très délicat, il ft
mamanipuler avec grand soin. Je
susuis assez d'accord avec ce qe
memes collègues viennent de dir,
jeje pense que c'était pas habie
dede fermer la porte carrément u
nenez de l'homme blanc et de die
: : tant pis. En même temps, je
crcrois, si je peux élargir le
dédébat encore plus que
l'l'extérieur des universités,
dadans les entreprises, dans les
coconseils il y a une fraction
miminuscule de femme, ça augmene
unun petit peu, mais très
lelentement. Donc, si on ne pred
papas de mesures pour essayer
d'd'accélérer le changement,
mamalheureusement, on va être
enencore largement minoritaire
dadans cinq ans, 30 ans, peu
imimporte. Oui, je pense que c't
lologique de dire : essayons de
trtrouver des façons de faire en
sosorte que les femmes, les gens
dedes communautés culturelles, s
auautochtones, etc., puisse avor
auaussi, percer le plafond de
veverre. Ça peut vouloir dire
trtravailler en amont sur le
babassin de candidats, de dire x
fefemmes, l'automne, peu import,
onon va vous prendre, on va faie
enen sorte que vous puissiez
momonter jusqu'au sommet. Ça pet
vovouloir aussi dire de Maître
totoute sorte de quotas, le tere
fafait peur, mais dans certains
cacas, d'essayer d'arriver à une
rereprésentation qui est
memeilleure, qui est plus
paparitaire. C'est vrai que dans
cecertains cas, ça peut
dédésavantager à compétence égae
l'l'homme blanc, mais en même
tetemps, comment on arrivera à e
paparité plus rapidement si on e
prprend pas ces mesures?
- - Pour une question d'équité,n
hohomme blanc qui voyait dans
cecette candidature sa chance en
fifin d'avoir sa chère de
rerecherche, par exemple, pourrt
didire : je suis victime d'un
prpréjudice, je pourrais
popoursuivre, je pourrais indiqr
leles chartes, parce que j'ai
momoins de trois dans ce contex.
- - C'est pour ça que je dis que
jeje crois que ça va trop loin,
fafaut quand même donner la chae
àà tout le monde de faire valoir
soson CV et puis aussi, on sent
tatant qu'il n'y a pas une femme
ququi voudrait nommer dans un
poposte parce qu'elle est une
fefemme. On veut évidemment tout
lele monde être nommé parce qu'n
a a les compétences qu'on a le
sesentiment d'être la bonne
pepersonne au bon endroit, donce
crcrois que tout cela doit entrr
dadans la balance, oui, on doit
dodonner la chance à tous les
cocoureurs.
- - Dernier mot là-dessus, parce
ququ'on voit vraiment qu'on a ue
grgrosse controverse comment on
ararrive à un baiser un peu?
- - Ce serait possible pour
l'l'Université Laval de revoir n
apappel à candidature, évidemme,
cece sera au département et au
cocomité de sélection à prendrea
dédécision à la fin de la journ.
- - La balle est dans leur camp.
VoVoilà. Merci beaucoup pour le